merci monsieur le président ma question
et pour monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre le nouveau
président du conseil français du culte
musulman monsieur mais ça vous y
rappelait hier que la majorité des
musulmans de france veulent vivre leur
spiritualité dans le strict respect des
valeurs de la république
il ajoute que la volonté de faire
reculer toutes les formes de
communautarisme et en accord avec les
idéaux de fraternité des musulmans son
prédécesseur monsieur boubakeur l'avait
dit la loi de l'état est notre lot de
son côté le président de la république a
réaffirmé hier qu'on ne doit jamais
accepté que les lois de la religion
puisse être supérieure aux lois de la
république avec le président retailleau
et le président marseille dans la
continuité de ce consensus républicain
nous proposons d'écrire dans notre
constitution que nul individu ou nuls
groupe ne peut se prévaloir de ses
origines ou de ses croyances pour
s'exonérer du respect de la règle
commune
pouvons-nous déduire de la déclaration
du président de la république que votre
gouvernement soutiendra notre
proposition
[Applaudissements]